the kids that know you when you're young
no one will ever know you like that
again don't give up on that you're gonna
let us in I hope you're right about this
not being a big deal of teenagers the
last thing they're interested in is what
their parents are doing
[Music]
it's time
or are they why is my mom's purse here
[Music]
this some Narnia's [ __ ] what is
happening
[Music]
get away
you don't have to hide
everybody so they just dropped The
Runaways trailer let's break it down if
you have no idea what's going on Hulu is
doing a Marvel TV series based on the
runaways comic
I'll explain where this is in the
timeline how this fits in with infinity
war and all the stuff that's happening
in present day in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like around spider-man
homecoming because these kids are
younger and how old their powers work
together because their powers come from
very different sources so it's actually
really cool and because it's on Hulu
they can have a little bit more fun with
it than if it's on network slightly less
censored but you probably recognize some
of the people in that trailer like James
Marsters from so many different Buffy
and genre things but it's basically a
group of high school kids that finds out
that their parents are super villains in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and then
obviously they say screw that so this is
coming November 21st to Hulu so I will
be doing videos for the first episode
and as many as you guys want be sure to
subscribe to get everything and what I
think they're going to do with this is
that instead of like Netflix and
dropping all the episodes at once I
think they might be airing at one
episode at a time and I believe it's
somewhere between 10 and 14 episodes but
the basic team is Alex Nico Carolina
Gert chase and Molly and then on the
other side of that the sort of evil
team-up that these parents are part of
is called the pride so the whole thing
in this trailer is them just learning
that for the first time but they even
tease the Velociraptor that's right
there's a Velociraptor on this TV show
their parents are a collection of mob
bosses Time Traveller's dark wizards mad
scientists aliens in telepathic mutants
so it's sort of a hodgepodge of a bunch
of different types of powers and
abilities so you see how they can have a
little bit more fun with this it's not
like all their powers come from the same
place but Alex here is just a child
prodigy he sort of leads the team with
Nico she's a witch
Karolina is an alien gert actually has a
telepathic link to this dinosaur you can
think of it as a velociraptor it's
slightly different it's not exactly like
that but that's probably what people
will call it chase has these really
futuristic gloves and then Molly finds
out that she has super strength so like
I said it's a combination of tech
wizardry mutants
people from the future and aliens so
this is all coming in November so just
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think of this so far obviously this
is the first time that Hulu's done a
Marvel TV series and this is sort of a
younger spin on that so it's closer to
being in spider-man homecoming territory
do me a favor though Happy's kind of
your point guy on this stuff stress
amount don't do anything stupid
I've seen his cardiogram alright yes
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do there's a there's a little gray area
in there and that's where you operate
what does that mean then I'm gonna
venture though is that 7th floor I can
take that up you don't have to take it
you're gonna take it thank you
she wins wins her next step was an ex
retreat you know what next mission yeah
in the mission the missions will call
you do you have my number no I mean
we'll call you like someone will call
you oh all right
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you these characters are all
about the same age as Peter Parker but
obviously it's the same situation with
the Netflix TV shows crossover with the
movies this Hulu thing probably exists
by itself so it'll be interesting to see
how they reference what's going on in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like they
refer to it as the incident the big
shatori invasion during daredevil season
1 and season 2 so they can probably just
have a little bit of fun with that like
you would imagine that teenagers would
probably talk more about all the cool
stuff that's happening more than adults
do this is taking place in present day
so we're ramping up for infinity war
that hasn't happened yet the main point
of crossover is Thor and Doctor Strange
there's mutant stuff that goes on in
here but they might change that to
Inhumans for the TV show just because
you can't do mutants in the Marvel
Universe it's a little bit weird with
the rights issues once we get episodes
I'll point out the more specific Easter
eggs but it is pretty cool to know that
there's this much connectedness with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they're
sticking relatively close to the comics
so if you want to read along you can
just pick up that first runaways run
it's like literally Runaways number one
but their first big arc is called
teenage wasteland this would they find
out what their parents are doing they
hit the road they actually go on the run
legit and their parents try to use some
really
various means to try and track them down
so this is really a story about the kids
versus their parents so we know a lot of
you asked about cloak and dagger and new
warriors the other series that they're
developing we don't know a whole lot
about that those will debut next year
sometime but this is coming in November
this will be after the Punisher I know
that they kind of delayed that because
of what happened recently so I'm
expecting Punisher footage to drop in
the next couple of weeks too but that
will still probably end up dropping in
November there were theories that they
might drop it early in October but then
the Las Vegas thing happened and they
just decided to postpone it because of
the subject matter just felt
inappropriate to be doing that at Comic
Con right now but all in all it seems
really promising they've already shown
the first couple of episodes to critics
and my friends that got to see it said
that it was really badass in a way that
some of the other new Marvel TV shows
didn't quite live up to expectations if
you know what I'm talking about so if
you're bummed out that a lot of Marvel
TV has not been on the level recently
this seems like it'll deliver but like I
said this is coming to Hulu November
21st so if you don't have Hulu this
would be the reason to get that but
obviously they have a whole bunch of
other stuff too I feel like that was the
reason everybody was really pissed off
at Star Trek because it's like I already
have Hulu and I already have Netflix I
don't want to pay for a third streaming
service so no worries about that for
runaways but they'll probably be some
more footage more trailers before it
gets here so just let me know how you
guys feel about this and if you want me
to do videos for it but what will happen
is is there'll be a new Justice League
trailer on Sunday there's some new flash
that I'm gonna post in a little while so
while you wait for that you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty and
you can click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
to stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight